[Music]
in matchmaker reward news submitted by
Abigail something high-tech hungry a
young CEO is offering $10,000 to whoever
can find him a girlfriend an ass [ __ ] if
we were all as because if we were all
seeing all right now how hard would it
be to go on a date I honestly think my
heart I think it's ugly as [ __ ] because
okay if you look at this right if you're
a decent a successful CEO people come to
you people come to your number one to
you beyond tender three you probably on
ballers tinder you know there's like
like we're like hi people of social
class where they meet Peters ballers -
yeah there's tender for regular people
and there's like millions of other
platforms for people that I thought it's
called ballers don't think that if
you're a CEO your car you're constantly
in meetings you're meeting you're going
to networking things that you just in
you're just you're socializing you're
not [ __ ] behind a computer all day
again depends on what kind of CEO you
are there's just a million ways of
meeting girls if you're a CEO this is
the way people without money think about
people with 30 years old name is Joe so
he's young yeah and he has a great name
that's attractive that's [ __ ] all you
need is this fall thirsty as [ __ ] like
every date he goes I just ruins it cuz
he [ __ ] premature ejaculate or tries
to ask him to marry them on the first
date or maybe he's too [ __ ] picky and
doesn't have a realistic realistic
expectation of the real woman's well
let's see a picture of them and let's
see this ball Chinese guy / why is he
offering $10,000 to the person who finds
a new girlfriend versus just given
$10,000 to the girl
or finding a professional matchmaker yep
I wouldn't whenever you fly have you
seen in the magazines there's like a
professional matchmaker wanna meet
successful singles yep you never seen
that [ __ ] no or [ __ ] go on a website
get a mail-order bride even better
that's one way yeah I don't know about
that I want to see a picture
well you guys are talking
- yeah what kind of company is it is a
[ __ ] a manure company where you don't
get any groupies at all cuz if it's a
tech company get hella groupies it's a
tech company okay
yes polish let's judge the [ __ ] out of
this guy's photo so he's the CEO of a
company based in California called self
hacks does he smell what's bad smell
tact is a website where you kind of you
get tips and like blog posts about ways
you can hack like a bio hacking you can
hack your body or Wow like health
hacking this time that's really cool
what exactly is bio hacking yeah Ferg
even have like cold showers in order to
like yeah you know waking lined up and
trained and discipline your body and
also like to force your like metabolism
to like reconditioning yeah stuff like
that actually work more like fasting for
like certain periods you know and I mean
like oh that's hard this is Joe it's all
behavioural yeah oh you should be fine
you should get a girl easy he's not a
yeah he doesn't look he's gonna have a
[ __ ] up personality than dude yeah cuz
he's a handsome man yeah what's wrong
any smart but I know what it is what is
it Geo it's not that he can't find a
date he's pushing his [ __ ] product so
now we're all talking about it cuz we
want to know what type of entrepreneur
he is now she just talked about bio
hacking over a new campaign yeah agenda
smart man and maybe a lot of girls would
start hitting on him after this article
let's see it
so Justin doesn't know you posted on his
website and she'll check on the blog
portion titled soulmate hack print
semicolon $10,000 reward for anyone who
sets up Joe with a girlfriend and now
the intro here he wrote so I'm all about
hex and I'm trying a new HEC to find a
long-term girlfriend this is an
experiment to see if I can find a
quality woman through this
unconventional way most hacks don't end
up working but they are worth a shot
I'm pretty serious about paying whoever
successfully sets me up you can take it
to the bank I will be following up to
let people know how this experiment
wish me luck and so he just goes into
his background so he's originally from
New York he moved over to California he
say he has a very limited circle of
friends or like social networking and so
he's saying that you know usually you
end up dating people that you meet
either at bars or like through friends
it's usually through friends and so
since his group is so limited like she
doesn't have that many options and so
he's she's always really busy with his
work she's tried the dating apps but
they always end up failing like he's
never found anyone that he's really
compatible with and so he wanted to try
this out especially putting a reward on
it it'll up his chances exponentially
and so he that's what he's saying that
he wants to try out this hat has he
tried eHarmony he's tried online dating
madbull if you so [ __ ] busy that you
can't date you're gonna be too busy to
even develop a [ __ ] relationship in
the [ __ ] first place it takes time to
cultivate yeah relationships take time
you can't it doesn't [ __ ] matter
that's like he's giving four months he's
getting like if he can find four months
is a joke that's what you need years
years cuz you four months you don't even
get past the freaking infatuation phase
yet you're still in it I kind of think
it's funny that he has a business built
off of hacks and he just said that yes I
was waiting for my turn to say that does
it make any sense oh he's realistic you
just [ __ ] on your own product I can say
like hey I sell Fitness progress but the
end of a network yeah so like what
that's a huge misconception on his part
about what a relationship is to like you
know what I mean can't hack a
relationship don't have enough time to
sit down and have a conversation with
somebody you're not gonna have enough
time to develop a relationship but you
know you know it's merely the fact that
like his his circle of friends are like
who he can connect with is just so
limited so he wants to try out he's
trying to expand his how many ladies he
can find he's trying to expand his
circle beyond Chinese and Indian people
and he's trying to do it fast so yeah
because it takes time to like go to go
to these meet up groups and then he's
trying to increase his chances yeah
plus plus you think about like the the
quickness and the intention with it
right you know when people like me in
general
small talk is about finding things and
then you kind of transcend through that
line of like maybe we can talk
romanticism yeah people who mean on
dating apps you're already there you
already know that you're like needing
specifically for that so you kind of cut
a lot of beginning to know you stuff if
somebody's gonna be in a situation where
somebody else received $10,000 sit down
and I'm like to be a girlfriend they're
probably like jump cutting a lot in
order to understand if it's gonna work
out so like time you already know
there's interest he doesn't have to
waste his time trying to court whatever
yeah
so I she's invested on it's like he's
put his money where it's not this so
even as a girl you might be like okay
this guy took it seriously he's not
paying me he's paying somebody else like
a serious amount of money to see if I'm
truly compatible paying the hooker know
so he's also saying that if the girl
goes to him directly then she could
either make a decision of donating the
ten thousand dollars to a charity or
using the ten thousand to go on a trip
together so he's even opening it up for
a broker women already so these other
requirements he says I'm using some
terms here that are scientific in nature
so if it sounds a bit weird than it is
this is a reason why you have a date
number one physical attraction to
intelligence three high on
conscientiousness parentheses competent
reality reliable thoughtful deliberate I
think everybody wants those things but
also the way he's putting it the [ __ ]
is getting dehydrated as you slowly yeah
she's getting dryer and dryer low on
neuroticism low vocality low on
eroticism yeah so he's not that horn so
he's looking for sandpaper [ __ ]
he said eroticism or neurotic neurotic
Oh party both words spoken in a
first-date setting is [ __ ] [ __ ]
drying well maybe this is his weeding
out process because he wants women that
communicate this way and are just as
nerdy yeah I see so then under low
neuroticism is low volatility which is
hostility anger and pulse Ignace
instability off that list the next one
is low withdrawal which is anxiety
unhappiness slash depressed depression
self-consciousness
next bullet you better have all of these
qualities himself he's looking for a
psychopath is what he's really yeah
let's continue this next point is
easygoing what open-minded honest
authentic kind these are all normal
traits that everyone wants yeah and even
if you find somebody with these exact
same trace house you know this is gonna
this is standard for both I think
everybody wants to these are his pluses
in to help self-aware funny warm direct
slash blunt not materialistic good
cuddlers Jewish these are like pluses
you really made this small they got Jada
calm or some [ __ ] right Jewish meets
Jewish like some Jewish dating site
maybe this guy sounds like he's never
ever had a girlfriend before in his life
that's what it really sounds like it
does sound good it's it's so unrealistic
and stupid because what you'll find out
in relationships too it's like the stuff
that you thought you hated in somebody
it's stuff that you actually tolerate
and you might even enjoy yeah like you
don't get everything on the list it's
just not possible yeah the reality is
the people that you love about that
person lot of things that you hate about
that period exactly when you meet this
person in you go oh my god this person
is so nurturing and caring that person's
that same nurturing and caring is gonna
annoys you because you're like why the
[ __ ] you so worried all the time because
she's nurturing and caring that's why
the same reasons why oh my god I love
your cleanliness I love that three years
later you're so [ __ ] OCD why do you
have to do everything assert this fool
is so stupid because I mean keeping the
relationship two examples we lose that's
the problems we have well that's real
that's reality the same things that you
love about a person fall for they're
gonna annoy you cuz what this guy is
doing is he has junior high wants but
he's just articulating like an educated
adult exactly when you blow past all the
words it's just like this fairy tale
junior high type of girlfriend eyes look
it's [ __ ] stupid there's got money
now so that's how I was trying to find
it yeah I hope he finds exactly what
he's looking for to put teddy bears and
lockers of shoes citizen only thing that
anybody should really write is like
stuff that our definite knows and then
there should be the other end of the
positive is just somebody that gets me
that's it yeah no AIDS
yeah like I would love children you know
it means stuff like that yeah that kind
of stuff and then somebody who
understands me that's all about it
because everything else is just a
developing and learning process with the
human being because there's no way that
somebody is piece perfectly perfectly
together like this yeah you could think
it but that's because you've already
made concessions in your mind because
you love that person that's it and the
whole part of what makes a relationship
rewarding is how how much you fight for
it yeah how much you learn and grow from
it oh yeah and how much struggle like
after the struggle once you grow that's
where the reward is something like the
nicest [ __ ] you guys I said all day
that's great because it pisses me off
when people have this unrealistic view
of how people should be yeah and it's
like it's like a [ __ ] fairy tale is
maybe not his fault because this is just
programming from you know movies or
whatever's going on but everyone has
this unrealistic expectation of what
other people should be they get in a
relationship and this is why we have so
many [ __ ] divorces is people can't
they don't have the discipline and they
don't have the complications to [ __ ]
fight it through and continue and if you
have a realistic expectation of how
human beings are then you won't be you
won't you won't it won't it will
blindside you like oh my god
I can't believe she's this way it's like
what the [ __ ] you expect [ __ ] a robot if
you want to control every aspect of it
yeah and then the girls gotta walk into
the situation look at this like laundry
list of like 50 different things that
she has to be for the rest of her life -
yeah you know what I'm saying she has
expectations for him well it goes both
ways you know and like Gio said - if you
have this list you better damn well be
sure that you're gonna [ __ ] fulfill
that [ __ ] - on the other end Jill
because if you have that type of high
expectations you should be able to
fulfill it the other way around you got
to put that on yourself a lot about
himself his hobby was music references
even here the entire ancestry but it
doesn't mean he's kind doesn't mean
intellectually stimulating it does what
if her requirement that she needed some
guy without a receding hairline
you're [ __ ] yeah well we're something
other than a v-neck you're [ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]